สวัสดีค่ะครู
ฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์อ่าุหญิงกำลังตกใจนะคะ
แบบอซูมขึ้นฟังก์ชันใหม่อุ๊ยวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 22 ค่ะเดือนเนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคม
อืปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
256  6 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
คะเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
คะพรุ่งนี้วัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไร
คะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 10:00 น
อ่า 10 นกี่
นาที 7 นาทีค่ะห 1010 นเหรอคะ 7 อ๋อ 7
นาทีครูหญิงได้ยิน 10
น 10 นาเนาะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยพูด 10  10
7 นาทีนะคะครูฟ้าเป็นยังไงบ้างคะตอนนี้
ครูหญิงกำลังงงๆนะคะซูมมันทำไม
ทำอะไรทำไมครููฟ้าไม่เห็นใหม่เลยอ้าปกติ
เวลาสมมุติอันนี้เป็นหน้าจอซูมใช่ไหมยคะ
หน้าจอซมอตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นรูปครูฟ้าแล้วก็
ครูหญิงเวลาครูหญิงจะเขียนที่หน้าจอเนี่ย
บาร์มันจะขึ้นตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าอือ่าจะ
ขึ้นตรงนี้แล้วครูหญิงก็กดๆๆอ่ะครูหญิงจะ
เขียนหรือว่าครูหญิงจะลบอย่างเงี้ยมันจะ
อยู่ข้างบนแต่ตอนนี้วันนี้สุซูมเนี่ย
เปลี่ยนใหม่จากอยู่ข้างบนแล้วก็เปลี่ยนมา
อยู่ข้างๆมาอยู่ตรงนี้แทนผุหญิงก็เลยงงๆ
แบบเหมือนเราไม่ชินใช่มยคะมันใหหรือว่า
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงแชร์อะไรผิดหรือเปล่าครู
ฟ้าก็เคยนะ
ไม่เหรอไม่ๆๆครูหญิงคิดว่าครูหญิงเมื่อ
คืนใช่มยคะตอนกลางคืนวันวันเสาร์มั้งอ่าอ
วันเสารคอพอ Window  New  Window ไงมันก็
เลยแบบ New  Zoom นะคะคิดว่านะคะนักเรียน
อือือัปเดตนะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
กินได้นอนได้เข้าห้องน้ำได้ย
คะกินได้นอนได้โอเคนะคะเพราะครูฟ้ากิน
โอเคนะคะฟ้ากินโค้กด้วยนะคะนเนบอกไม่โอเค
ครูฟ้ากินโกไม่โอเคช
คครูฟ้าก็กินนโอเคซีเรียวนะ
คะนักเรียนบอกครูฟ้าครูฟอไม่กินอาหาร
หรออาหารก็คือแบบเราอาจจะเป็น
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ก็ได้นะแฮมเบอร์เกอร์แซนวิช
ข้าวอันเนี้ยเป็นอาหารครูฟ้ากินขนมอ่ะกิน
ช็อกโกแลตดื่มโค้กอันนี้คือครูฟ้าคิดว่า
กินได้ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าโอเคกินได้อ่ากินได้ไ
นอนได้
มย
นอนช่วงนี้ครูฟ้านอนไม่ได้อ่ะ
อ้าทำไมแปว่าตอนนี้ครูฟ้าก็นอนนิดหน่อย
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้านอนนิดหน่อยน่า
จะ
โห 3 ชมงต่อวันเหรอคะ 1 วันครูฟ้านอน 3
ชั่วโมงอันนี้ไม่โอเคครูฟ้ากินได้โอเคครู
ฟ้านอนไม่ได้ไม่โอเคแล้วครูฟ้าเข้าห้อง
น้ำได้
มยเข้าห้องน้ำได้
สิไม่ใช่ว่าูฟ้า
เดินไปเข้าห้องน้ำ
อ่ะไม่ใช่ก็เวลาที่เรากินอาหารใช่มั้ยคะ
เรากินอาหารครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำอ่ะโอเคเวลาที่
เราดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำมากๆเราก็จะปวด
ฉี่ก็เข้าห้องน้ำอันนี้คิดว่าหลายๆคนก็
โอเคนะแต่ถ้าเวลาเรากินอาหารใช่มยกินๆๆๆ 1
วันเนี่ยเนี่ยเรากินอาหารตอนเช้าออืออื
ตอนกลางวันอืแล้วก็ตอนเย็นใช่มั้ยคะเรา
เนี่ยกิน 3 ครั้งแต่ถ้า 1 วัน 2
วัน 2 วัน 3 วันเนี่ยครูฟ้ากินแต่ครูฟ้า
เข้าห้องน้ำไม่ได้ผู้หญิงไม่ได้หมายถึง
ครูฟ้าเดินเข้าห้องน้ำแต่ว่าอือูฟ้าเนี่ย
กินิิแต่ไม่ไปห้องน้ำอันนี้ก็ไม่ดีนะปวด
ท้องเลยนะคะนักเรียนปวดท้องใช่
เออครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบเข้าห้องน้ำค่ะเข้าห้อง
น้ำแต่แต่ออกนะเนี่ยนักเรียนดูวีีดีโอเย
กินข้าวไม่ได้อีก
ะใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าหยุดกินเออคุอีิงคิดว่า
นะไม่ว่าเราจะกินหรือเราจะดื่มอืปูหญิง
เนี่ยนะคะถ้าเวลาที่ครูหญิงอยู่ที่บ้าน
อ่าอยู่ที่บ้านเนี่ยครูหญิงก็จะมีแก้วน้ำ
แก้วน้ำ 2 แก้วอยู่บนโต๊ะอืจะดื่มน้ำดื่ม
น้ำดื่มน้ำเยอะมากๆไม่กลัวว่าดื่มน้ำดื่ม
น้ำดื่มน้ำแล้วจะแบบปวดชี่เพราะว่าเรา
อยู่ที่บ้านที่บ้านเราเนี่ยมีห้องน้ำใช่
มั้ยคะเราปวดฉี่เรากินอาหารปวดท้องอยาก
เข้าห้องน้ำก็เข้าได้ตลอดเวลาแต่ถ้าครู
หญิงไม่อยู่ที่บ้าน
อืไปข้างนอกบ้านอย่างเงี้ยค่ะสมมุติไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตก็ยัง
โอเคเนาะในในในช้อปปิง Center
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตเนี่ยที่ไทยเนี่ยมีห้องน้ำ
เยอะๆจริงๆอยู่ที่ไทยเนี่ยโอเคนะคะที่
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยใชเวลาดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำแล้ว
รู้สึกโอปวดฉี่หรือกินอาหารกินอาหารแล้ว
แบบโอ๊ปวดท้องปวดท้องอยากเข้าห้องน้ำที่
ไทยเนี่ยโอเคโอห้องน้ำห้องน้ำห้องน้ำห้อง
น้ำห้องน้ำมากๆอืแต่คุหญิงเคยไปอเมริกาโอ
ุหญิงไม่อยากกินไม่อยากดื่มอะไรเลยอ่ะครู
ฟ้าผู้หญิงคะคือคืออะไรคะมันหาห้องน้มัน
หาห้องน้ำยากมากๆจริงหรออือถ้าจะเจอห้อง
น้ำก็คืออ่ะ Starbucks โอเคต้องเดินเข้า
Starbucks เข้าห้องน้ำแต่ไม่ใช่
Starbucks ทุกที่มีห้องน้ำไงเอ้าบางที่
ก็ไม่มีห้องน้ำหรอครูหญิงไม่มีห้องน้ำ
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตบางที่แบบประเทศไทยเราก็
จะมีอะไรนะโเทสโกมั้ยเค้าเปลี่ยนชื่อเป็น
เทสโกแล้วป่ะอืเทสโกหรือว่าเอ้ยหรือโลตัส
นะู้หญิงไม่แน่ใจเนี่ยเทสโกโลตัสแล้วกัน
อ่าบิ๊ซีอย่างเงี้ยโหมีห้องน้ำเยอะมากๆ
อือๆๆแต่แบบที่อเมริกาบางทีแบบไม่ค่อยมี
ไงก็แบบไม่เอาไม่ดื่มเดี๋ยวปวดฉี่อยาก
เข้าห้องน้ำไม่มีห้องน้ำที่ออสเตรเลียมี
นะคะ
หรอครูฟ้าขอคิด
ก่อนที่ออสเตรเลียโอเคมีห้องน้ำหรือว่าหา
หาห้องน้ำง่ายๆใช่
มั้ยง่ายมยหรอว่ากำลังคิดประเทศไทยนะคะ
นักเรียนเพราะประเทศไทยเนี่ยง่ายส่วน
ออสเตรเลียูฟ้าก็ไม่รู้เพราะว่าครูฟ้า
อยู่แนบนะ
คะแล้วครูฟ้าก็ 1 วันเครูฟ้าไปทำงาน
ก็โอเคมีห้องน้ำครไปเรียนก็มีห้องน้ำไง
แล้วครก็กลับบ้านนะคะไม่ได้ทำอะไรอมันก็
มีห้องน้ำอ่าที่ที่โรงเรียนใช่มที่โรง
เรียนที่ครูฟ้าเรียนมีห้องน้ำที่ร้าน
อาหารใช่มยอันนี้เป็นไทยร้านอาหารไทยใช่
มั้ยอืแล้วก็เป็นอาหารส้มตั้มเนี่ยที่
ร้านอาหารไทยก็มีห้องน้ำที่บ้านครูฟ้าก็
คือครูฟ้าบ้านโรงเรียนโรง
เรียนบ้านบ้านบ้านโรงเรียนโรงเรียนบ้าน
แค่นี้อ่ะก็เข้าใจเข้าใจเออถ้าแบบเราอยู่
ที่ที่มีห้องน้ำใช่มั้ยคะแต่คือประเทศไทย
เนี่ยมันง่ายๆอย่างคอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิง
อย่างเงี้ยอือันนี้ที่บ้านที่คอนโดของครู
หญิงใช่มั้ยคะถ้าครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามาหาครูหญิง
ครูฟ้าอันนี้ครูหญิงอยู่ที่นี่ใช่มั้ยอ่า
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าบอกฮัลโหลครูหญิงครูฟ้าจะไป
เจอครูหญิงที่คอนโดมิเนียมผู้หญิงบอกโอเค
พอครูฟ้ามา
ถึงครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยากเข้าห้องน้ำอือ่าแต่
ครูหญิงคิดโออันนี้ห้องครูหญิงใช่มั้ย
ห้องน้ำที่ห้องครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่โอเคเลยครู
หญิงยังไม่ได้ทำความสะอาดไม่อยากไม่อยาก
ให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเข้าห้องน้ำที่คอนโดของครู
หญิงอืจะรู้สึกแรู้สึกไม่โอเคก็ไม่เป็นไร
นะไม่เป็นไรนะครูฟ้าเพราะว่าข้างหลังตรง
นี้คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงเนี่ยข้างล่างตรง
เนี้ยมีห้องน้ำ
อืใครก็เข้าได้ครูฟ้าไม่อยู่ใช่ครูฟ้าไม่
อยู่คอนโดที่นี่ก็เข้าได้แล้วก็แยกแยก
ด้วยนะอืมแยกด้วยนะ
คะเดี๋ยวนะแป๊บนึงนะงงๆอยู่แยกห้องน้ำผู้
หญิงห้องน้ำผู้ชายนะแยกกันอ่าอ
อือมันก็โอเคไงเพราะว่าผู้หญิงเข้าห้อง
น้ำผู้หญิงมคะผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำผู้ชายมัน
ต้องเป็นเจนเดอร์ใช่มยก็โอเคอืเพราะว่า
บางครั้งเราคิดออห้องน้ำในคอนโดมิเนียม
หรือว่าห้องน้ำบางที่เนี่ยอาจจะมีห้องน้ำ
เค้าเรียกว่าห้องน้ำรวมก็คือมีห้องน้ำ
เนี่ยห้องแบบนี้อาจจะเป็นคล้ายๆประมาณแบบ
นี้ได้อยู่นะเนี่ยแบบเนี้ยค่ะก็คือเป็น
รวมแบบเนี้ยคืออันนี้ผู้ชายใช้ได้ใช่มย
ผู้หญิงก็เข้าที่นี่ได้อย่างเงี้ยก็คือ
ห้องน้ำรวมมี 1 อันนี้ไม่มีนะนักเรียนมี
แค่นี้ในห้องน้ำมีแค่นี้อ่าคือเดินเข้าไป
ในห้องน้ำก็จะเห็นโหฉี่ของผู้ชายแล้วก็
ซักโครกของผู้หญิงอืซึ่งครูฟ้ากับครูหญิง
เป็นผู้หญิงก็เดินเข้าไปนั่งซักโครกถ้ามี
ผู้ชายมาแต่ว่าเราก็ล็อคนะไม่ใช่พร้อมๆ
กันนะนักเรียนแต่คือ
พ้อมผู้หญิงเข้าได้ผู้ชายเข้าได้เรียก
ห้องน้ำรวมแต่ที่คอนโดครูหญิงเนี่ยแยกนะ
แยกผู้หญิงแยกผู้ชายซึ่งครูหญิงคิดว่า
ห้องน้ำทุกๆที่ก็แยกผู้ผู้หญิงแยกผู้ชาย
เนาะแยกกันใช่ค่ะห้องน้ำหลายๆที่ห้องน้ำ
ทุกที่แยกผู้หญิงแยกผู้ชายปกติอแล้วแบบ
ครูฟ้าเคยเห็นห้องน้ำที่ออสเตรเลียที่ไม่
มี gender มั้ยอืมีมั้ยคะที่แบบว่ามันจะ
มีห้องน้ำผู้หญิงห้องน้ำผู้ชายใช่มแต่บาง
ครั้งเจะมีห้องน้ำที่
แบบอะไรก็ได้คุณไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงไม่ใช่ผู้
ชายเค้าเรียกอะไร No  gender เหรอ
อืที่ไทยเนี่ยครูหญิงไม่รู้มีมยแต่ครู
หญิงยังไม่เคยเห็นนะคะยังไม่เคยเห็นอืครู
ฟ้าที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยนะคะแยกผู้หญิงผู้
ชายนะคะปกติออืใช่ทุกที่ว่ายใชอืออืว่า
ที่ไทยก็แยกผู้หญิงผู้ชายแล้วก็อาจจะมีก็
คือเป็นห้องน้ำครอบครัวก็คือพ่อ
แม่แล้วก็ลูกใช่มั้ยบางทีมีลูกชายลูกสาว
อ่ะถ้าคุณแม่กับลูกสาวเนี่ยเข้าห้องน้ำ
ผู้หญิงได้คุณพ่อกับลูกชายก็เข้าห้องน้ำ
ผู้ชายได้แต่บางครั้งั้งมันไม่ได้เป็นแบบ
นี้ใช่มคะอาจจะเป็นแบบคุณพ่อกับลูกสาว
อย่าง
เงี้ยลูกลูกสาวเป็นผู้หญิงก็ต้องเข้าห้อง
น้ำผู้ชายแต่ลูกสาวอายุ 5
ขวบเอ้ยลูกสาวเป็นผู้หญิงก็ต้องเข้าห้อง
น้ำผู้หญิงคุณพ่อเป็นผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำ
ผู้ชายแต่ลูกสาว 5 ขวบเข้าห้องน้ำผู้หญิง
คนเดียวที่แบบช้อปปิ้งเซ็นเตอรคุณพ่อก็
ไม่โอเคใช่มั้ยอืๆๆเพราะว่าลูกยังเด็กๆนะ
คะอายุ 5 ขวบเข้าห้องน้ำคนเดียวไม่โอเคไง
อ้าใช่หรือ
ให้ลูกสาวไปกับคุณพ่อโอเคมยเออลูกสาวเข้า
ห้องน้ำผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำผู้หญิงค่ะคุณ
พ่อเนี่ยนะคะหะกับลูก
สาวผู้หญิงคิดว่าลูกสาวโอเคโคคุณพ่อโอเค
แต่ผู้หญิงที่อยู่ในห้องน้ำผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ตกใจเฮ้ยทำไมผู้ชายเข้าห้องน้ำผู้หญิงอ้า
ก็ลูกสาว 5 ขวบไงนี่นะนักเรียน 5 ขวบเข้า
ห้องน้ำคนเดียวไม่ได้เ้าก็ต้องเข้าห้อง
น้ำกับคุณพ่อ
ไงแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าอยู่ในห้องน้ำผู้หญิง
เห็นผู้ชาย 1 คนอ่ะอายุซัก 35
ปีมากับเด็กผู้หญิงอายุ 5 ขวบครูฟ้าจะรู้
ได้ยังไงว่าเ้าเป็นพ่อลูกจริงๆเ้าคิดเรา
อยู่ในห้องน้ำใช่มยเราเป็นผู้หญิงบาง
ครั้งเราก็กลัวว่าแบบ
เอ๊ะเป็นพ่อกับลูกจริงๆมั้ยเป็นคนไม่ดี
แล้วก็เด็กไม่รู้ที่ไหนหรือเปล่าคิดไม่ดี
หรือเปล่าแบบเนี้ย
อือ้าถ้าครูฟ้าเห็นครูฟ้าก็คิดพ่อลูกใช่
ครูฟ้าคิดแต่ว่ามันจะมีบางคนไงเออที่เขา
อาจจะแบบตกใจหรือผู้ชายคนนี้ที่เป็นคุณ
พ่อก็รู้สึก
อืมไม่โอเคแต่จะคุณพ่อลูกสาวเข้าห้องน้ำ
ผู้ชายคุณหญิงคิดว่าคุณพ่อก็ไม่
โอเคคุณพ่อก็ไม่โอเคนะเพราะคุณพ่อก็รู้
สึก
เอผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเยอะคุณพ่ออายมั้ยเออไม่
มันไม่โอเคอยู่แล้วไคุณพ่อกับลูกสาวเข้า
ห้องน้ำผู้ชายนี่ห้องน้ำผู้ชายคุณพ่อก็
คิดเ้าลูกสาวเป็นผู้หญิงยังเด็กเดินเข้า
ไปในห้องน้ำผู้ชาย
อืสักครู่นะคะเดินเข้าไปในห้องน้ำผู้ชาย
อาจจะเห็นผู้ชายยืนอยู่ลูกสาวตกใจหรือ
เปล่าใช่มมคะที่ไทยเนี่ยเขาก็เลยมีห้อง
น้ำครอบครัวแบบนี้แหละค่ะก็คือคุณพ่อเป็น
ผู้ชายพาลูกสาวเข้าห้องน้ำที่เป็นห้องน้ำ
ของครอบครัวได้ผู้หญิงเคยเห็นที่ช้อปปิง
เซ็นตที่ไทยแล้วผู้หญิงก็คิดเฮ้ยดีมากๆ
เลยนะคืออืคุณใช่มั้ย
คุณแม่แล้วก็พาเด็กผู้ชายสมมุติเด็กผู้
ชายคนนี้อายุ 7 ขวบแต่ 7 ขวบเหมือก็โต
แล้วมั้ยอื 7 ขมันก็ก็โตอยู่นะคะแต่ว่าก็
บางทีก็อยากเข้าห้องน้ำกับลูกไงอืแต่ว่า
ยังเล็กอยู่อืเข้าห้องน้ำไม่เป็นก็มีนะฮะ
ใช่คือคุณแม่กับลูกชายแล้วเข้าห้องน้ำผู้
หญิงเนี่ยคนไทยที่เป็นผู้หญิงเนี่ยรู้สึก
ธรรมดาอไม่เป็นไรโอเคอ่าใช่เป็นผู้ชายก็
จริงแต่เป็นเด็กยังเด็กอยู่ออือแต่คุณพ่อ
กับลูกสาวเข้าห้องน้ำผู้หญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิง
ไทยเนี่ย
แบบไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยเออไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้แปลก
มากนะคะใช่ใช่ค่ะพอตอนนี้ที่ไทยเนี่ยนะคะ
มีห้องน้ำครอบครัวแบบนี้แต่จะมีแค่ 1
ห้องนะ 1 ห้องเท่านั้นอ่าเวลาเราเดินเดิน
เข้าไปใช่มั้ยคะอืเวลาเดินเข้าไปเราจะ
เห็นอ่ะสมมุติอุ้ยยังไงล่ะเนี่ยถ้านัก
เรียนแบบถ้าเราเดินเข้าไปใน shing  Center
ใช่ไหมเวลาเราเดินอันนี้ครูหญิงเนาะ
อ่าแล้วก็เดินๆๆก็จะเห็นอันนี้เป็นห้อง
น้ำครอบครัวก่อนเลยพ่อ
แม่แล้วก็ลูกนะคะห้องน้ำครอบครแล้วก็
เสร็จแล้วก็จะมีมีอันนี้เป็นประตูใช่มั้ย
เป็นประตูอ่าอืส่วนใหญ่เราจะห้องน้ำผู้
ชายใช่มั้ยอันนี้อสมมุติอันนี้ห้องน้ำผู้
หญิงอยู่ทางนี้บางที่เลินเดินเลยห้องน้ำ
ผู้หญิงก็จะเป็นห้องน้ำผู้ชายเยเราก็เดิน
ครูหญิงเป็นผู้หญิงก็เข้าห้องน้ำผู้หญิง
อ่าอือบางคนเป็นผู้ชายก็เดินแล้วก็เข้า
ห้องน้ำผู้ชายแบบนี้ก็มีแต่คิดว่าที่ไทย
ตอนนี้ค่อนข้างน้อยนะคะเพราะว่าบางทีผู้
ชายชายเดินผ่านห้องน้ำผู้หญิงก็โอเคเนาะ
ว่าห้องน้ำผู้หญิงมันค่อนข้างปิด 100% อื
ใช่มันก็โอเคไงแค่เดินผ่านนะคะนักเรียน
ไม่ได้เดินเข้าไปมันก็โอเคอ่ะใช่ใช่ค่ะ
แต่ว่านี่แหละแต่คิดว่านะคะตอนนี้เนี่ย
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีห้องน้ำผู้ชาย
ห้องน้ำผู้หญิงห้องน้ำครอบครัวคิดว่าตอน
นี้ 2  0  2  3 ใช่มยแต่ 2  0  2  4  2  0
2  5 คิดว่าที่ไทยก็อาจจะมีห้องน้ำที่
เป็นแบบ No  gender
อืคิดว่าน่าจะมีแต่อาจจะไม่ใช่ทั้งหมดอาจ
จะเริ่มกรุงเทพฯก่อนอมีห้องน้ำที่แบบอถ้า
บางคนที่เค้าข้างนอกเป็นผู้หญิงแต่เขาก็
ไม่สบายใจเข้าห้องน้ำผู้ชายไม่สบายใจเข้า
ห้องน้ำผู้หญิงอย่างเงี้ยก็อาจจะเป็นห้อง
น้ำที่เป็นแบบอ No  gender นะคะซึ่งห้อง
น้ำครอบครัวในตอนนี้ครูหญิงก็คิดว่าดีมาก
แล้วก็ถ้านักเรียนอยู่ประเทศไทยหาห้องน้ำ
ง่ายมากๆไม่ต้องกลัวไม่ต้องไป Starbucks
นะคะ Starbucks ประเทศไทยไม่มีห้องน้ำนะ
นักเรียน Starbucks ประเทศไทยไม่มีห้อง
น้ำเลยค่ะใช่ไป shing  Center โลตับิ๊กซี
อย่างเงี้ยมีห้องน้ำนะคะนั่นละค่ะก็
วีดีโอนี้เราเลยมาคุยเรื่องของห้องน้ำนะ
คะนักเรียนฟังแล้วอาจจะรู้สึกแบบออเหม็นๆ
มย
เหได้ค่ะส่วนวดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ